i know how many people will come out and  say whatever for him that's his power  that's why i wrote the op-ed is i was  speaking to that phenomenon how many  people will come out in support of him  and will fall to his power he is a very  powerful man and people love carrying  favor we're powerful men correct and i  know that firsthand jail time for  committing perjury  excuse me  i didn't i didn't hear your question  excuse me question  ms vasquez if you do  please just repeat the question i didn't  hear you curry favor and commit perjury  in this courtroom  i have a powerful man i have seen people  do this time and time again  that's why i wrote the op-ed